[Music]
I bet you never thought you'd see a
Lamborghini going off-road in the Mojave
Desert
[Music]
here we are out in Joshua Tree
California it's about an hour east of
Palm Springs so we're way out in the
middle of nowhere with a Lamborghini if
you can imagine it the Lamborghini
Huracan Serato this is the off-road
version and it's also the end of an era
because it's the last V10 internal
combustion engine that Lamborghini will
ever make so it's kind of a big deal
it's also been a long time coming we saw
early versions of this car in 2019 it's
finally here the base price is 273
thousand dollars I hear it's going to be
really fun to drive I can't wait to go
try it
[Music]
all right
with brutalist undertones and a low
seating position the Serato comes with a
601 horsepower V10 engine and 413
pound-feet of torque it has all-wheel
drive a 0-60 mile per hour Sprint time
of 3.4 seconds and a top speed of 161
miles per hour
now don't feel bad if you're a little
skeptical about this 273 thousand dollar
Supercar I was too Lamborghini has no
record of success in off-road rallies in
the 60 years since the brand roared to
life but it hasn't stopped the brand
from jumping into the off-road mix I
spoke with Lamborghini head of design
mitcha bowkert about what makes the
Serato different from a normal Huracan
our design DNA is about the single
Center silhouette you can always tell a
Lamborghini in front view with the
inclinated windows
every car of Lamborghini that's my
mission has to have his character
so for the customer it's clear what is
the car so we took it in a higher
position we have a slightly longer
wheelbase we have bigger Wheels more
important of course the rally cross
Wheels we added the cladding we kept it
quite rough because we wanted to give
this tough and rugged feeling
it's the everyday super sports car you
don't need to care you just drive that's
a car that is your your partner for any
Adventure
it's unbelievable what the car
I was driving this thing harder than I
drove the rivian truck rougher than I
drove a Porsche 911 or a Land Rover in
the sand dunes I came out of the car
grinning from ear to ear wow
[Music]
[Applause]
but now I wanted to see how it did on
the pavement passing by the Joshua trees
in desert dry Hills the strato just
cruises man it's pretty fun it's pretty
great to go directly from the dirt onto
an asphalt surface and I have to say
driving in Joshua Tree is the perfect
way to explore both sides of the car
the hurricane Serato has three main
driving modes strata Sport and rally now
rally is the one that we used when we
were going off-road that's where
everything's super loose very minimal
stability control basically just the ABS
is on now we're in sport mode which is a
more generalized mode it's perfect for
driving some of these back roads in
Joshua Tree
Lamborghini is going to be introducing
more and more hybrids we've already seen
the rualdo and we will soon see hybrid
versions of the Urus as well so this
really is in a way the end of an era for
Lamborghini the last V10 with an
internal combustion engine it's pretty
cool to be able to drive it
my take is the Huracan Serato is a
joyful Ode to the contrarian nature of
Lamborghini Lamborghini is making just
1499 of them deliveries begin this
summer
[Music]